[Music]
fine oh this is a very cool show
explores the the 70s the music scene
yeah these New York City rock and roll
the rock and roll scene in the seventies
I play a record company a label owner
yeah with Bobby kind of always a star I
miss partner but it's pretty yeah it's -
it's so cool I don't know what I'm doing
it it it's so good you're very good in
the show and an added bonus you are
naked on this program well you're gonna
be meeting a lot of guys at stop signs
no no this is a warning this is not a
plug this is a warning in Episode seven
for some reason HBO wanted you know HBO
I don't I guess they have insurance or
something but they they wanted me yeah
it's it's scary it's it's a frightening
thing you got a sex scene in that yes
yeah yeah and here's the thing it's it's
just it's stressful because I had to be
drunk also and even as an actor that's
even more stressful because you got to
do that the right way you got it the
right levels put it this way the
director is not gonna yell too big
during the nude scene I'll tell you that
right now well I had a sex scene which
didn't go over well with with the wife
your wife not happy about the sex scene
well she made me describe it you say
tell me what happened tell and not you
know what it's all fake he's you know a
woman is straddling me I'm telling and
blah blah blah and it took a while she
handled it okay I got our candle but
what happened was she she was in New
York when I was filming that she flew
home and when she got home I called her
on the phone and I said how was the
flight she goes oh good there was a
there was an actor sitting next to me a
young Latino actor and he gave me his
card and so now I'm stuck questioning
her like what you mean because I'm not
good with that yeah and I'm getting a
little jealous what did he gave you the
car why well because she knows he knows
you and then I'm so I'm saying well what
he looked like is that what was his name
and finally she stopped me she goes what
was the name of the girl that's sat on
your
okay I didn't know I didn't know her
name she doesn't really make it sound
man there it was a threesome it wasn't
just one girl I'm sorry I didn't I hate
to say this but I hope she doesn't watch
this because I didn't tell her was the
threesome if and when she watches I'm
just gonna tell her we we green-screen
the other girl in there later yeah CGI
yeah we like the bear like Leo with the
bear there's a lot of wrestling but the
she wasn't even there right I was on a
cable than right right great music in
vinyl off mean you've got Mick Jagger is
involved in this projects you've got and
as for says II they always get the best
music in their projects I mean it's from
the 70s it's it's just music I grew up
with and you know I was a teenager so
it's such a landmark moments in my life
that this music had an effect on I mean
we get Led Zeppelin's in the pilot
actors playing Led Zeppelin right and
for me I mean I lost my virginity to the
first three minutes of stairway to
heaven I remember that exactly and that
includes that includes the apologizing
you didn't even have to what you did you
audition first courses I did audition I
put myself on tape and we sent it to him
and the feedback we got was he he likes
what he did and he's never heard of him
or seen him before what yeah yeah it was
like the most-watched TV show for like
ten years no not with geniuses like you
know he's not a TV guy your audience
will love to hear that
[Applause]
how can I get out of that one
hello I gotta buy everybody a candle no
I mean heat yes yes he's no he's a movie
yes yes he watches movies that's all he
does but it's and there's be no you yes
because he didn't he had no you know he
didn't know Robert ray Barone for nine
years wasn't in his head so I mean I got
the job that way which I kind of I'm
glad it happened that way